good morning hick it'ss Tuesday so this
is my last like normal video of 2023 and
as years go uh I I won't be sad to say
goodbye to this one it's been a rough
year but I've been thinking a lot about
Hope and how and where to find it and
maybe this can be one example of how and
where so for the last few weeks the time
for five Coalition of TB activists have
been calling renewed attention to the
price of drug resistant TB test
cartridges there advertisements on bike
shares and on a bus stop near the
headquarters of the company that makes
the car cartridges and also there is an
ad in today's Washington Post which is
where the company in question danaher is
headquartered so one thing we don't talk
about enough is that these test
cartridges are amazing I mean in a
couple hours caregivers can know which
antibiotics a particular individual's
tuberculosis will respond to and then
usually that means that it can be cured
within 6 to n months of the right
antibiotic regimen I know of one TB
Survivor fuma tsil who during her three
years and eight months of drug resistant
TB treatment took between 20 and 30,000
pills and also lost her hearing because
of a drug that it turns out she didn't
even need to take all that happened
because at the time this miraculous test
didn't exist and now it does exist which
is a cause for Hope and celebration it's
also such a testament to the power of
research and the scientific method and
the sharing and diffusion of knowledge
and to the talent and hard work of the
people who work at sephi the subsidiary
of Daner that makes these tests because
I haven't been particularly good at
being hopeful lately I don't think I've
spent enough time marveling at the
astonishing
multi-generational Global collaboration
that has led to all of this progress
like if we hadn't identified the
bacterium that causes tuberculosis in
1882 if we hadn't come up with
increasingly better strategies to kill
that bacterium we wouldn't be here today
TB wouldn't be curable this is where I
find Hope in community in collabor
operation in making meaning together by
making change together I find Hope in
the Wiis of my life the Wii of TB
Fighters the Wii of nerd Feria the Wii
of my family the Wii of Indianapolis
it's getting weird to say wi over and
over again but you know what I mean I
think I'm looking for Hope and
collaboration and Community because
that's where people together can battle
what Kurt vonet called the terrible
disease of loneliness while also
battling other diseases like
tuberculosis and other forms of
Injustice but of course collabor ation
doesn't mean never disagreeing it means
often disagreeing hopefully in
respectful and empathetic but still
passionate ways because when lots of
people are working together to find the
best way through within that lots of
people there will always be Divergent
value systems and perspectives and
everything else and that's not just okay
it's essential like here's one example
of what I mean danaher and sephi it have
lowered the price of their standard TB
test cartridge and pledged not to make a
profit in low and middle income
countries on those tests which is
amazing but they haven't lowered the
price of their test cartridge for drug
resistant TB which I'm sure from their
perspective makes sense but from our
perspective as TB Fighters doesn't make
sense because our only priority is
lowering the global burden of
tuberculosis which we think is best
accomplished through cheaper and more
abundant testing that's a big
disagreement over an issue that
contributes to hundreds of thousands of
deaths every year but danaher is not the
enemy to tuberculosis is the enemy to
NTB we need each other and I think
together we can drive down costs further
and make testing more affordable that's
my hope is it naive I just don't think
it is because I've seen hope be realized
before it's utterly unacceptable that
200,000 people are going to die of drug
resistant tuberculosis this year and
that most of those people will never be
able to access one of those amazing
molecular tests because there simply
Aren't Enough of them available it's
very frustrating to me that with
existing resources say we could test
twice as many people and danur could
still make money if the tests cost half
as much all of that is discouraging but
what is encouraging to me is the broad
multi-generational series of
breakthroughs that led to this test in
the first place and my belief that
activists and Advocates working together
can find ways to get more tests to more
people more affordably and danah her can
and I believe will be an ally in that
fight Hank I think it's safe to say that
this has been the hardest year of your
life and what you've been through has
been brutal it's also been one of the
hardest years of my life but I finished
the year feeling that there are two
human capacities that have carried us
this far and by us I mean both you and
me and the broader us our capacity for
collaboration and our capacity for Hope
to hope is to refuse to accept the world
as it is and it is through collaboration
and indeed only through collaboration
that we can bring about a better world
Hank I'll see you on Friday